another attack that's terrified
ukrainians and horrified the world
it was the middle of the afternoon when
the missiles hit
a fire ripping through this busy
supermarket and shopping center in
central ukraine
[Music]
the flames hindered rescuers and
soldiers from reaching people feared
trapped in the rubble
a senior government advisor was one of
the first on the scene
i'm standing at the site of yet another
of putin's vile and cynical attacks on
the peaceful ukrainians i'm increment
chuck behind me is burnt down amster
supermarket where people were grocery
shopping
it was never a military object
the strike comes just a day after
russian missiles devastated two
residential buildings in the capital
kiev a nursery school playground was hit
in the same attack
the kremlin continues to say it is not
targeting civilians but these
indiscriminate strikes continue to
happen
and in this instance president zielenski
said there were more than a thousand
people inside the shopping center
fortunately as far as we know now many
people managed to get out before the
strike they were assisted out after the
air raid siren but there were still
people inside when it hit employees and
some visitors
only terrorists who have no place on
earth could strike on such a location
this is not a mistaken missile strike it
is a calculated russian strike on this
shopping center
the timing of these bombings could be a
power play by russia to world leaders at
the g7 summit in germany
but the civilian casualties may instead
strengthen president zielenski's hand as
he calls for air defense systems and
more urgent support
meanwhile ukrainians are living in a
state of terror
not knowing what or where will be hit
next
sally lockwood sky news in central
ukraine